Democrats are now deciding which which
of president Trump's crimes to include
in the articles of impeachment they have
to decide yes so far they've got bribery
obstruction of justice and fathering Don
jr. that's that's gonna he could get the
chair for that one is the latest point
when told he was being impeached
president Trump told the Democrats to
quote get it over quick yes
after hearing us Melania said I tell him
that every time let's make it past and
move on according to a new poll that
just came out in California Bernie
Sanders is ahead of both Joe Biden and
Elizabeth Warren Bernie Sanders way
ahead although although Bernie is still
trailing baby Yoda
[Music]
apparently crushing I think baby Yoda
could get elected right now yeah I like
a lot of his dad's drinking standing
looking at him frog-eating today Nancy
Pelosi said she doesn't hate the
president because she's a Catholic and
Catholics don't hate people
I just want to say as a lifelong
Catholic I thought that was the funniest
goddamn thing what is she talking about
we hate everybody we're the best haters
in the world who are distorted view
Catholics are leprechauns yes we are